Vaughn is in Oahu hey Vaughn welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show hi thanks for
having my call sure how can I help
I just met the fiduciaries of my aunt
and uncle yesterday and I thought they
were investing for them and I found out
annually for the last 12 years
both my aunt and uncle are spending
forty nine thousand dollars in a whole
life insurance plan
who's the what kind of fiduciary well
they're not capable making their own
decisions you know they're just
financial planners they found over a
decade ago and they've stuck with oh
okay my fiduciary you mean just a
financial planner okay yeah that's what
I meant
well this fiduciaries been screwing them
for a while so what how did it how come
you met with your uncles and aunts guy
oh because they the financial planners
they're in California and they come to
Hawaii once a year and I just happened
to be at the house when they came over
to show them their returns and financial
planning because they're planning to buy
a building for a business mm-hmm okay so
they're they're really not dealing with
a financial planner they're really
dealing with an insurance agent that's
polarizing as a financial planner yeah
they do invest but they only invest 400
into a simple IRA for their business and
they're there would you call it expense
ratio is 1.8% mm-hmm really I think
that's a little ridiculous
and so when you broach the idea with
your aunt and uncle that they should get
a different person helping them with
their money because they're in
absolutely horrific investments what do
they say well our grandma just passed
away without any insurance or their
parents just passed without any
insurance so they're afraid
canceling the whole life plan and
switching to the term and the closer
they are to retirement age they think
the term will be the same at the whole
life plan so god yeah and how many years
have they been putting $49,000 in the
ground yeah so who's the 500000 you know
if it was just sitting there a fruit jar
they'd have enough to bury them if they
had made no return yeah and they're not
even gonna get back what they put in so
I don't know I mean here's the thing
their cash value probably is 300 grand
so I don't understand what they're
worried about about being buried well
$300,000 not bury them or I mean well
these people King Tut their insurance
that their life insurance plan is 1.5
million now they don't need life
insurance two old people sitting
together in their recliners that have a
half a million dollars in mutual funds
don't need life insurance mm-hmm is they
got enough to live on and they got
enough to bury them why do you need
insurance yeah if you've got money you
don't need insurance kids are grown and
gone we're retired we're sitting here on
a pile of money and you use ten thousand
dollars of your million to bury one of
you if you die you don't need insurance
it's a far stretch from your grand ball
down with no money yeah you don't need
insurance so I don't know if we can talk
to them off the tree you're not here
they're pretty far up it but the answer
to the equation is I would find out what
their actual assets are and can have
those that with a real investment
professional who actually could show
them how to invest all of that and they
have enough to bury them and they have
enough to live on live or if one of them
dies the other one's gonna be fine and
have someone sit down and show them that
because I suspect they've got enough
assets here in spite of the fact that
they've been so poorly invested
hopefully they've been long the entire
half-million dollars that they put in
this whole life crap so don't even
switch the term
you don't need term if you got enough
money you know okay let me stop a second
all right let's just walk this through
with me Vaughn okay you're 60 how old
are they
they're 54 they plan to retire when
they're seven okay let's just say you're
you're 54 years old and you have a
million dollars in mutual funds your
kids are grown and gone and your house
is paid for okay
your house is not paid for you okay we
got to find out a few of these things
but if if they have enough money and
they don't have any debt their need for
insurance is gone there maybe for the
next five or six years they need for
insurance I'm 58 in good shape and not
great shape but good enough that I can
get term insurance and it's not that
stinkin expensive if I need some I paid
a premium this morning as a matter of
fact if I want some term insurance I can
get some and it's not it's nowhere near
that kind of money yeah I mean geez man
I mean for what they're spending they
could buy like sixty million dollars
worth of term insurance at 54 years old
this is just ludicrous assuming they're
reasonably healthy but the point of term
insurance is to replace income that you
are creating for your family but if you
don't need to replace income you're
creating for your family because you
have enough money then your need for
insurance has gone way is that logical
yeah that's logical and so what we've
got to sit down and look at how much
money they if they took all the money
away from these goobers that they're
with I'm trying to be nice oh it's just
so devastating because they've lost the
cash value yes yes for God's sakes get
it out of there because you know what
happens to cash value when you die no
they keep it okay all you get is the
face value of a whole life policy
so whatever the cash value is is gone
and they paid through the nose for this
over as this is
five to a ten million dollar mistake
they've made over the last decade that's
how bad this is this is why I can't
breathe right now
okay and it's not even my aunt and uncle
so anyway and I can't allow them to go
another decade and make another five to
attend me in dollar mistake all in the
name of I need to be buried yeah that's
my point because grandpa was poor when
he died well they're not poor they got
enough money to plant them okay so
that's not the issue here
the issue is how to maximize these
dollars for a much better rate of return
then one of the worst financial products
on the planet is cash value life
insurance it's absolutely horrendous
horrible rates of return highest fees
ever and when you die they keep your
money oh it's horrible it's the payday
lender of the middle class and so yeah
they need to run away from this person
as they can with all their money I don't
know if we'll be able to talk them into
it because they're pretty entrenched in
this stupidity but oh man it's a ten
million dollar error you know the next
decade it's another ten million that's
how far this thing's this is not even
close to fiduciary fiduciary means
you're supposed to be acting as someone
else's best interest not screwing them